climb Evan Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from jason who is one of my
newsletter readers from sacramento
california so thanks for the question
Jason wrote in saying that it's long
email so tried to summarize for you guys
so he lost his job last week and his
wife has been very supportive in in that
process he wants to start his own
business his really strong passions in
person development motivational speaking
and relationship advisor / expert he
feels a rush to get back into the 95 job
because he has to make money for his
family he's thinking about instead doing
something in network marketing to try to
create an income to to bring home one of
my advice on you know what network
marketing adventures might help him and
he doesn't want to live the rest of his
life making thirty thousand dollars a
year and wanted my advice on what to do
so thank you Jason for the question
sorry to hear about your job but I'm
glad you see it as an opportunity that's
a common characteristic of successful
entrepreneurs is taking you know things
that most people see as a negative and
finding a way to make it a positive it's
just a network marketing I don't have a
lot of experience doing that with
marketing I think for you the most
important thing is not necessarily
finding the right network marketing
experience but focusing around something
that you are really passionate about so
you say it's around the personal
development relationship expert kind of
field if that's what you're really good
at that's what you're really passionate
about and in your email here you you
made that you know a little bit bolder
and capital letters so that's good shows
you're really you know excited and
passionate about it so that's where you
should focus and it may not be your own
product and there may be network
marketing products out there to help you
you know those products you can sell if
it's tony robbins or brian tracy whoever
it is people who you respect then that
could be an opportunity it doesn't
necessarily have to be something that
we're marketing though and i wouldn't
jump on something that's outside your
your your field of interest i know not
just something to try to make money but
something that you feel you
really touch people's lives with where
you can add a lot of value to them and
you want them to say thank you you know
what you did really change my life and
that will not only be really personally
fulfilling for you but it's also the
start of a business opportunity the more
you able to help people the more money
you're going to be able to make so for
you I would start trying to find
opportunities look at things that have
impacted your life if there's a product
or service that you use or a specific
coach or speaker who you really respect
you've gone to their seminars and you've
bought their cds and books maybe that's
where you start and see if they have an
affiliate program because if they've had
an impact on you that's the thing that
you're going to be able to convey to
other people really easily if it's some
brand new product that you have no idea
what you're selling and you don't use it
yourself if you're not in love with it
your clients are going to love it and
it's not going to come through they're
going to go find something else so focus
on what you're really good at it's also
going to bring you a lot more joy and
satisfaction now I don't want to say you
know don't get a job but with the job
aspect here there is an opportunity and
a lot of successful entrepreneurs
started by having a part time job I
think if you're going to have a job to
do it in a field that helps you grow in
the area of interest that you're in so
if it'll get a 95 job even it is full
time 925 do it in something that will
help you learn about the area that you
want to start a business in it can be
tough to start a business you know
full-time right away without having any
kind of income on the side so if you're
going to get some income on the side do
it in something that's going to help you
learn about personal development
relationship expert how to build up that
kind of business so try to find those
kinds of opportunities so when you're
ready to go launch your business full
time you have some experience there
already built up this is nothing wrong
with starting part time for you if
you're going to make money remember the
magic ingredient here is adding value so
the longer term success you'll probably
find is creating your own products and
services if you if you become a coach
yourself or you're at your own books or
create your own CDs or DVD program or
whatever it is you have to add a lot of
value to the people who are going to buy
it the more value add
when you gonna make and so you have to
think about what is unique about you and
your story and how you deliver your
message that people will really attune
to and want to you know connect with you
and buy your products and hire you to
speak and coach them and that may not be
worked out yet it may be too early days
for you you may know that you're really
good at it and you want to learn more
about it but you don't quite know how to
package it all together yet and that's
fine that's part of the learning
experience you're not expected to know
everything from the start so that's
where trying different offerings will
help so you especially a service is
often the best way to start because it
gets you close to your customers so
start some kind of service based
business so you're able to really
connect with people one-on-one learn
about their challenges and from there
you can branch out and create products
but also if you do get some kind of part
time job in your industry then that'll
teach you you know how to be able to
grow business in that company in that
kind of market and then also give you
some ideas so what is missing from the
other companies out there and a hole
that you could potentially fill with
your product or services so hopefully
that helped good luck on the launch of
the business it's an exciting and
terrifying time I'm sure for you for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes one of the more these videos
for you and if you have a question about
this video or question about your own
company feel free to leave it in the
comments below I always read those and I
try to respond to as many as I can so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
I
you